Hi android db deployment program engine is in favor of ng today
I'm going to talk to you on the inside of this new cortex especially.
WebView in the Android 4.4 kit is based on Crumann
Implemented
The latest html5 css3 javascript standard technology even better support and performance
There have been many improvements in terms of
There have been a lot of changes in the internal implementation, but basically,
You can use the same way to see
However, there are some caveats and additional features that are
I'll explain about it today.
The first thing to note when using Web View in a multithreaded environment
I'll tell you.
There are two oldest adjectives about relief associated with threads:
First, Android ui should end up with this dew first. Second ui
Do not burn the thread
There is no exception when using web b
It is a simple code that starts a background thread and displays it in a thread
The code that loaded the page
Is this code correct? As in the case of other views,
Work on WebView should always be done a lot for ui
But before Kikeri, this type of code has been allowed.
This code will not work from version 4.4 until now.
Starting with Android 4.4, you will not be able to
Using the ui thread method or the assertion task,
Work must be modified to be performed on ui liquor
Another principle is to call the ui thread and not be evil
At the end of the development of the Web is not clear Javascript function call
To wait for results, use men's slips or weights to
There are occasions when there is a bulakan.
It's not a bad way to catch JavaScript code in the background instead
A method that starts with a thread and easily receives the result
Added
This is the first argument of having Value Eto
Pass the JavaScript code you want to execute and get the result as the second argument
Register a callback function for
If you do not need to receive the result value, you can use the value of the intermediate transition null
Next, we need to make some changes
It is
Be sure to use custom u below Android 4.4
Below 2c 3986 you should use the characters of u u
I will
If not, why do not you expect your developers to click on the link
Dali pseudo override url loading callback method may not be called
There is
For example, using a problem that is not valid, such as a show profile,
Use it as a bow
Using the load or load data base url method,
When loading an html document Reason 1 Base 2 Unless specified
Putting an anecdote on a shoot-over is not cool - it will not be called at all
If the face exists below, the simple string combined with the base infant
Helpful infants of the absolute path format are affected by the crack method after being changed to Problem 1 4
The result value is passed
So when you use customization to handle app events,
Always use a valid URL, such as a unique schema, for example, on the slide
Please use letters
After that, in the actual callback function, the string is given preference in February
Based on the self-organized schema and the quality of the attracting data and the remaining data
You can do the same as before
Finally, we introduce the remote debugging function.
It can be debugged easily and remotely from WebView as the web is transformed based on
It was
The remote debugging setup is based on the premise that it is installed in the Android development environment.
A brief introduction to the method
First you need to install the Chrome browser 0 add extension
You can download it from the slide a url or you can download it from the Chrome Web Store.
You can easily find it by searching adb.
Next, you need to enable debugging on the app side
Web Python 3 web content Debugging within a call to a trio of fire methods
It's possible
In fact, this method only after the Android keycap version
You need to implement this method only to call the method because it is supported
There is
Also, in the market-launch version,
To avoid this problem, you can use the mug constant value
It's also a good idea to match your debugging path settings to your web debugging settings
Now it is actually a step to experiment with remote debugging #
Then select the View Inspection target item from the menu of the ad plugin
A list of connected devices and the debugable webviews running on each device
A list is displayed
Information about where each webview is located on the screen
Please note that why you choose p for debugging and vi vi pen
Click on the Spectro button
Then, just like desktop development on the web,
You can relinquish WebView without using tools
It's a really handy tool for developers. For example,
When you select a specific html element, the corresponding
The item will be highlighted
So far, I have briefly explained the chrome ear map.
So, for more information on Mapfy, visit the Android Developer site.
You can browse
Especially for those developers who have been using the existing envelope,
There is a Migration Guide document available.
Thank you.